[Music]
i was at a bookstore this weekend and uh
there's still a lot of holiday leftovers
on sale you know when you walk into a
bookstore and there's just books that
just didn't sell at the holiday and
they're still there and you can get them
for next to nothing and mostly they're
coffee table books that nobody wanted
you know coffee table books that just
didn't catch on they were so cheap i
bought a bunch of them because i thought
i'd share them with you in a little
piece we're going to call new coffee
table books
[Applause]
yeah
for example uh there's this one which is
pretty cool it's great moments in sports
as seen from terrible seats
buffalo bills and dallas cowboys really
these are a good game yeah yeah that was
a good game terrible scene for that guy
yeah that guy look at this one right
here this is the
1990s soccer world cup and
that guy's hat's just ruining everything
one of those cheap sombrero seats yeah
yeah those are the worst anyway this is
a book you can pick up for next to
nothing there's this one uh pretty nice
it's cats that are about to seriously
wound their owners
yeah and look at that that cat is about
to go nuclear right
such a relaxed photo yet so much tension
yeah he doesn't know and what i love is
he has no idea what's going on he's
happy cat is really pissed goodbye face
yeah actually here on the app
uh there are additional photos that you
didn't show oh one's like
ones ones that aren't here from that oh
look at that extra jokes check it out
you've got extra jokes they're on the
table there's some more cats that are
going to attack
and that guy that guy is just wearing
some very light cotton clothing yeah
easy for claws to get through he's
clearly going to be killed yeah
all right let's look at another book and
you follow along with this i will i will
here's one this is a a good book
it's
the uh banks around the world where mitt
romney has bank accounts
you can see it's a
beautiful
beautiful wow
that's that's a good one gorgeous book
very heavy this book i'm just gonna open
it over there you know hey here's
something neat about the app it actually
uh it has a pop-up here and it shows the
last time that we did this same bit so
you can refer back to it and say it
again
i remember i was doing that yeah yeah
that's funny so you can go back and sit
and so if you don't like this bit you
can go right right get another version
of it and hate it even more you don't
like the filling of this particular
dumpling you can get a similar dumpling
with different fillings very nice
everything's a dumpling everything's a
dumpling yeah dumpling or okay
your wc fields all of a sudden i'm
getting ready to continue apple app
nicely done chum
here we go look at this one it's a good
book former first ladies with mr t's
hair
this is a great book
fantastic and it's just chock full of
all kinds of
great first things look at there's a
whole first
lady
okay they all like this but i'm actually
going to comment on that beat what do
you write don't write a comment i don't
think these are real photos something
seems fishy
hey that's your real look at that's a
picture of you as a kid that's my
twitter picture oh that's so nice me in
first grade that's you in first grade
before it all went to hell
oh settle down it's not so bad
oh this is a great book this is i think
it's my favorite of all the coffee table
books it's the on fire skeleton from
ghostwriter having a relaxing weekend
and there he is he's doing yoga
[Laughter]
here he is with a lady i think that's
napa i'm going to say that snap but
they're enjoying some wine and when
you're on a skeleton on fire you gotta
have a rub down occasionally because
i think this is my favorite one back
here actually is the one on the back
taking a nice walk together and stirring
i think a brush fire i've also
i've also here on the app
i've got some additional uh some
additional books that were cut from
rehearsal that you can see only on the
app so you can get some extra stuff
these weren't good enough to make the
show venom
those are
denim
snakes
wearing denim
decimal points then and now okay yeah
kind of dull hey what is that one what's
chad christmas has uh chasmatazz
it's a celebration of all things
chaz
terry and chazz bono
[Music]
how could that have been cut how could
that have been cut from the show
tasmania